I sector theorem tells us is that you
know you have a triangle and you draw a
ray okay or a segment that bisects
meaning it cuts the angle in half and
you can see that you know I put the same
markings here and here to show that
these two angles are congruent they're
equal and so that this is in fact
bisecting the angle so what ends up
happening is that there's a proportion
that develops that we can utilize and
that's that the ratio of A to B okay a
to B is the same as this side C is to D
okay so very simple it's almost like
folding this triangle over you can say
you know a matches up with me C matches
up with D so very simple let's go
through an example so here we've got a
triangle here's our angle bisector you
can see that these are the same so we
want to solve for this missing side ax
so the ratio of 3 to 2 so this piece to
this piece is the same as 15 is 2 ax all
we have to do now is cross multiply and
solve and we've got it so it's 15 times
2 which is 33 times X is 3 X divide both
sides by 3 and you can see that x equals
10 and you've got it so I hope this
helped you to understand how to work
with the angle bisector theorem better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel
mario's math tutoring and i look forward
to helping in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon